amber heard arrived in court for yet
another day of cross-examination
it was another day packed with many
revelations
one time johnny was hitting me
and he was hitting me hard and
repeatedly
and i was screaming this was a statement
from 2016
submitted to court today amber heard was
questioned
about an alleged incident on a staircase
a year earlier
she claimed johnny depp hit her in front
of her sister
he was about to push my sister down the
stairs she was attempting to break us up
i am protected over my baby sister
in court today she said i did strike
johnny that day
in defense of my sister i heard the
rumor he pushed an ex-girlfriend down
the stairs
i think it was kate moss and that was
fresh in my mind
so i reacted quickly she added i have
been johnny's punching bag for years
and i remember this as it was the first
incident when i ever struck him back
but there were questions from depp's
lawyers why this argument about kate
moss hadn't been brought up earlier
they claimed heard was making things up
as she went along
the court also heard an audio recording
of an incident in a bathroom
between johnny depp and his ex-wife i i
remember hitting you as a response to
the door thing
and i'm really sorry about hitting you
at the door of it
or hitting your head i did not mean to
nor
you didn't mean to hit me in the head
with the door but you meant to
i didn't punch me in the jaw i meant to
hit you and
i i i did not do this thing with the
door i do
remember i did mean to hit you okay i'm
sorry i hate you i didn't mean to hit
you but it was in response i just
reacted in response to
my foot i just reacted and i'm sorry
it's below me
when questioned about it ms heard
claimed she pushed the door as an
instinct saying it was in self-defense
and despite continuous questioning
she denied she was ever violent towards
depp
there were further denials in court
today amber heard saying
she had no other relationship whilst
with johnny depp
but in text messages between her and
spacex boss elon musk
he offered her 24 7 security
he said it only matters because i really
like you
and this cctv footage was also shared
actor james franco
is seen in a lift with heard on the way
to her apartment
just hours after she fought with johnny
depp
the hollywood star denies all
allegations of assault and that he was a
wife beater
as branded by the sun newspaper in 2018
for a third day tomorrow he will watch
on as his ex-wife
testifies against him in zaman rashid
sky news